pour le moment il ya un scoop qui a fait
mal il m'a fait mal les chroniqueurs
vous allez le prendre dans la jugulaire
de téléspectateurs mecheri vous allez le
prendre en pleine face à rennes avant
avant avant toute chose je voudrais
rappeler qu'on a lancé il ya de ça
quelques semaines une émission qui
s'appelait qui s'appelle toujours
d'ailleurs parce qu'elle va revenir la
grosse rigolade ou ce sont des gens qui
racontent des blagues autour de la table
et w9
une fois de plus w9 on les aime bien et
je vais vous dire moi
les copieurs en classe je les aimais
beaucoup et on tv je les aime aussi
clément c'est à toi donc vous avez lancé
il ya quelques semaines la grosse
rigolade quelconque concours de blagues
en prime
eh bien à quelques semaines il va y
avoir un concours de blagues en prime
sur w9
il sera animé par issa doumbia
non
[Musique]
double
[Rires]
on va pas se mentir c'est honteux
une fois ce soir les mecs mais w9 c'est
jérôme fouqueray tiens si tu me regardes
jérôme appelle moi sinon c'est moi qui
vais t'appeler eux donc appelle moi
c'est le patron de w9
c'est franchement c'est choquant
j'aimerais savoir ce qu'en pensent les
téléspectateurs c'est choquant et c'est
pas la première fois que w9 fait ça ces
décos peter comme jamais kopitar voilà
c'est dit qu peter comme dit mama mama
fils et déco peter opus on les aimait
bien mais c'est ccoo alors oui le
concept est légèrement différent c'est
des mecs tu raconte des blagues des
belges face à des freins et il va
falloir savoir qui des belges ou des
français s'en est plutôt ce que vous en
pensez vous chez vous franchement est-ce
que w9 sont des copies teurs dites nous
la vérité dit souvent pensé tuer
quelqu'un j'ai une petite question comme
ça nous regarde c'est votre ami ce qui
vous a prévenu a donc pas dû faire ça
pas du tout les mêmes voies en plus ça
se déroule à mon avis il voulait
toujours le diront il voulait me le dire
et puis c'est dit c'est peut-être pas le
moment voilà oui c'est honteux parce que
ouais il ya quand même une propriété
intellectuelle enfin c'est du plagiat
pur et c'est vrai que ça va plus je suis
sûr que vous avez déposé voit que ça
marche i copies n'ont pas eu l'idée
je suis très triste par rapport à issac
dessus je l'aimais bien
et là je trouve que l'espagnol s'est pas
présenté à issa et la chaîne doit
retirer ce programme
oui c'est vrai c'est mes copines d'un
grand groupe comme ça c'est honteux on
peut parler vraiment franchement bien
sûr on va parler vraiment franchement
pourquoi ils le font maintenant moi
c'est ça qui me dérange
après si on est vraiment honnête avec
tout le monde il a concours de blagues
il ya dix quinze ans ils ne faisaient
les grosses têtes à prix à 10 15 ans si
on est honnête il nous faisait des
grosses têtes à vendre avant sur la
grogne est honnête on est honnête vous
avez fait la grosse rigolade tout le
monde le fait maintenant ils font des
blagues j'entends des blagues à la radio
j'entendais j'écoute beaucoup de radios
comme c'est gênant
chanson personne faisait d'elle ils font
tous des blacks vous vous faites la
grosse rigolade et maintenant ils
arrivent et ils font une émission aussi
c'est là c'est ça qui me dérange pas
maintenant mais après les blacks ce
genre existe une certaine il faut cinq
points de différence pour qu'on accusait
de plagiat
oui mais bon là c'est pouces en full on
va on va pas les attaques on est bien là
dedans d'accord nature tactique alors
excusez-moi mais alors on peut tous se
copier alors déjà il y avait un projet
paraît-il sur cette chaîne et que tan
dung quotidienne avec issa doumbia
exactement ce serait un brin palaja tpm
péter dalla avec moi que c'est vrai on
est d'accord donc c'est vrai confirme
son bail à plus de nouvelles à l'inversé
que il regarde attentivement ce que vous
faites sur sur s'est vite effectivement
je pense que c'est cesser de la pompe
sûrs et du purin ses récents de valérie
benaïm banon mais encore on copie de ce
qui fonctionne
oui mais bon et alors moi je vais pas
faire les marseillais sur ces huit
sessions s'est vite je vais pas faire
non mais franchement je vais pas faire
le les toulousains sur ces me tiens
c'est vrai on pas que oui mais
jean-michel ouais non je trouve ça
sidérant parce que une série corps une
grande chaîne w9 ce qu'ils aiment aussi
peu d'imagination pour pomper ce qui
marche dans les hauts-de-seine tout ça
et puis aussi vite comme ça c'est trop
côté d'un tas de programmation de la
gouvernance a qui arrivent bientôt si on
monte notre contrat c'est ce à quoi va
pas se mentir c'est honteux oui fanny
après aura mathieu vachon que c'est tout
à votre honneur on s'inspire de vous ben
naceur qui réagit pas c'est isabelle qui
est dans le groupe rtl
jérôme non mais est ce que vous trouvez
ça honteux pages tout ça ressemble oui
est ce que vous trouvez ça honteux
honteux tant que telle mais oui ça
arrange en sont un peu moins
effectivement je ne sais pas bien que
ces petits après il ya le professionnel
assez bizarrement il est professionnel
et humain
c'est pas tant le professionnel qui me
dérange une copie quelque chose qui
marche
allez c'est bon je comprends que tu as
une revanche mais sur l'humain et sur
l'humain c'est moi c'est issa qui me
déçoit parce qu'il cartonne sur w9 il
pourrait dire voilà j'ai mon émission
qui marche mais grand numéro jeu
puisqu'il fait tout ça qui cartonne
celle là voilà c'est 7 de mon pote celle
là fait là c'est pas moi qui l'aï golf
et sa carrière il doit rien à un coup
d'arrêt à cyril audirac et non mais
c'est pas voir ailleurs il a une vie
quand même dans l'émission ça na mail il
a démarré sur tf1 il a été dans
l'émission les questions lui a permis de
remplir des salles sauver connaissant
matthew des moines qui ont cartonné mais
c'est vrai aussi que ça aide quand les
yeux de deux émissions qui va mieux et
me perdre des spectateurs pour remplir
tes sales et je dis pas qu'il n'y en a
pas marché ça il avait pas non moi je
n'y tiens de l'humain là il aurait pu
juste te dire sur celle là où lassana
j'enlève ou au moins prévenir syrie mais
maintenant tu prévient tu dis cela avec
mes à donner de la voix dans la nuit il
est venu là l'autre jour appelée nova
c'est la même bouille c'est pas moi de
l'apesa l'uda et puis heureusement si
honteux c'est franchement isabelle moi
c'est marrant ça apparaît on s'est pas
un tribunal révolutionnaire pas quoi
merci entre rires oui je le comprends il
alla peut pas se mettre en porte-à-faux
demain aller sur arte est là bas sont
probablement des voisins de mission de
cordes ou là sur dix ans de moins je
sais je vous dirais que je ne vous parle
pas de ça merci ils vont retirer cyril
vous pensez pas qu'ils vont le retard
le pire c'est qu'à ce qu'on voulait que
la peau est le patron by sa mais il fait
déjà quatre ans maintenant on va vous
appeler ses seins si ça doit finaliser
je l'appelle tout aussi bien avec ça
mais ça ça mais dont on est jaloux de
lui faire une el kabbaj de quoi vous
vous foutez de ma gueule
je n'irai pas attirer une clientèle va
pas alors c'est pas vrai c'est pas le
genre ici on puisse une bourgade à
regarder mais non mais c'est pas jarry
s'explique généralement il est peut-être
en réunion et un truc d'accord ne peut
il pas en réunion passe temps passé
jérôme hesse et cyril hanouna voilà tu
te fous de ma gueule est donc au cours
de ma [ __ ] jérôme mon chéri si tu veux
que je vienne de vendre des programmes
tu n'hésites pas je te les frais à
moitié prix mais arrête de copier
monféry je vais pas faire les
toulousains sûr c'est mieux il ne fait
pas un concours de blagues sur w9 alors
que tu voulais déjà faire touche pas à
mon poste en face de moi au quotidienne
un secret que je t'aime beaucoup c'est
pas parce que je te bats au tennis à que
tu dois monter dans les tours et c'est
le maire a fait avant la fin de
l'émission qu on règle ça mon chéri je
n'aime pas les copies tu es d'accord je
t'embrasse
voilà arrête de copier cesse
voilà qu'on demande à de très bonnes
relations avec le groupe nrj trouve
quand même on vous voit le time in et
off quand même c'est rossi mais sert
aussi pour deux ans pour voir ce qu'ont
pensé téléspectateurs mais c'est
incroyable quand même ces voix-là
copieurs quatre motos perdu franchement
c'est inadmissible moi je vous dis c'est
incroyable pour moi voilà je les aimais
beaucoup là ils m'ont énormément déçu
sachez le les landes 6-1 le groupe rtl
le groupe w9 et vous aussi que ça va
battre buzz et j'en suis sûr parce que
français je vous le signe que dans
l'époque on est aujourd'hui ça va partir
dans tous les sens à coups de raser
liste part à six matchs un doublé n'y
fait c'est nul voilà on va pas se mentir
on les aimait beaucoup c'est nul ya eu
çà doumbia qui me magnée a doublé à kim
appelle ça comment ça va
[Musique]
calme-toi calme-toi bat inquiète issa je
viens d'apprendre je vais l'appeler
jérôme fouqueray on vient d'apprendre
qu'il faudrait faire un concours de
blagues sur w9
non c'est tellement garin tu veux que je
te donne son adresse
[Rires]
en tout cas bravo usa qui m'appelle des
rêves alors qu'est ce que ce matin c'est
quoi cette histoire ça va être mon chéri
tu vois c'est vrai mon bébé et c'est ce
qu'on a dit c'est un mec bien c'est ce
qu'a dit mathieu elle pourrait pas
isabel coixet toutes les ampoules un
flux de messages tu te ressemble
si ce temps paraît si s'emballe pas non
réponse
je sais pas lesquels fouteur de merde ce
que les mots d'arabe qui habite dans
bien des problèmes clément quand même
parce que non c'est fini c'est bien le
chant brouillé avec ses 8 à cause de lui
là on verra son budget propre enseigne à
cinq minutes de la fin rien w9 est
toujours en amont avec ce fait part des
choses
le français avec un concours de blagues
et cela soit pas il aurait pas de
chroniqueurs vers pas comme mon chéri
fait d aller sans vidéo qui cartonne
d'ailleurs très bien et du moment thème
force rapporte qui sera supermarchés en
effet d'énormes bisous et en attendant
la grosse rigolade les permuter émission
génériques ils le traînent çà n'existe
qu'on t'aime mon chéri le van houten
force
je t'embrasse je sais pas qui lui de
regarder france 2 ce soir et il ya
lucien jean baptiste qui fait de
regarder france 2 ce soir à eybens
lucien jean baptiste regard mon émission
je m'assois
ça comme ça
et non je dois rappeler qu il n'a pas
dit qu'il n'avait pas démissionné
il existe deux mois sur l'émission c'est
sûr et samuel et qui anime généralement
constitution j'ai prévu après rappelle
jérôme fouqueray le patron de w9 ac pour
la deuxième fois et excusé c'est la
valise rtl dont il est le montant sur
ces séries là tu veux signer chez rob
s'est encore cyril hanouna bien vouloir
j'ai peut-être que petite info qui
viennent de tomber concernant ce projet
de concours de blagues alors apparemment
et ça ne fera pas de nom maintenant
est-ce que ça va se faire ou pas écoute
moi j'ai toujours donné de bons conseils
les blagues à la télé c'est de la merde
ça marchera de la colonie donc laisse
tomber clément est ce que tu es sûr de
cette info à 3677 pour ça jérôme gt
à la base
venu en ami m'excuser mais comme le
piment d'espelette train de me dire
giraud bruno je me rappelle moi au plus
vite mais réglons ça à l'amiable vient
demain en basket devant la mairie ksar
said tu fait de tes fond c'est ça qui
s'achève et je viens droite ont un
formateur oui hélas il a trés bonne info
apparemment ça va se faire les chantres
et coûte moins bien la vie de ma mère à
3000% bon ben j'ai rappelé jérôme poker
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors je la porte de son enclos défoncer
tout ce qu'il a à sarcelles demain
rappelons que mon frère je veux dire que
c'est mon frère tu me fous la merde
comme enchères sa tasse à je manque les
mots je suis à mon contrat mais si ça
tient au corps et âme aux médecins mais
sans lui faire le flux en syrie on
s'entend comme ça il fait quand même
d'excusé le caire on verra ce qui fait
savoir le pourquoi de son père sans
l'anah son amour sans juifs ont fait un
saut à 4 ans pour un attentat d'aden et
1500 pour 5 100 % en es source ira
jamais sereine géraud issad et cyril
hanouna et d'amis ton frère - jérôme g
de plus amples informations
à lyon-ii
ce serait sûr
notre chaîne e
voilà je veux savoir si tu es bien des
chocolats leonidas
[Applaudissements]
mais on est là c'est qu'on s'est créé
que je peux avec la noisette à
l'intérieur il est magnifique le thème
dessine on est à l'étape de jérôme a
toujours été le meilleur en télé en
france a toujours eu les meilleures
idées
voilà mon bébé je t'embrasse avait bien
entendu ne vient pas demain sarcelles 1
cette année déjà plus tôt à la maison on
vient prendre le petit-déjeuner l'ami
ricoré je t'embrasse
c'est encore mon nice a donc bien est-ce
que tu pouvais te dis mon numéro de
téléphone
la jeune fille bien sûr c'est fanny
négocia alors figure toi quel alors elle
méfie-toi d'elle apparemment elle est
sur un concours de blagues sur tf6 aux
séries alors est-ce que je m'en occupe
d'accord je m'ennuie je t'embrasse je
t'aime en bas c'est issa il est sympa et
ça sympa ça tous les mets bien et ça ça
va parce qu'il n'a pas fait l'émission
c'est vrai il est venu en messages et
conversations nuances à 100% mais
vraiment sans pour ce bon voilà donc les
chéris j'espère qu'on aura des nouvelles
de w9 groupe m6 du groupe rtl
ce concours de blagues et d'un train de
me flinguer la soirée et paix rhdp c'est
un feuilleton c'est une cible alors
voilà eh bien j'ai eu des news pendant
la pub
j'ai eu le patron de w9
jérôme fouqueray super sms et j'ai
toutes les infos je vous le dis déjà je
voudrais embrasser mon issa qui me dit
voilà qui est le truc il le fera il le
fait pas du tout il fait pas du concours
de blagues et mercialys à nous avoir
rappelé que c'est que je t'aime fort et
j'oserais dire et c'est vrai qu'à chaque
fois qu'il fait un projet
ils m'appellent pour avoir mon avis tout
ça et c'est voilà il est d'ailleurs je
vais toujours dit qu'il était excellent
en animation et je le redis si vous le
savez j'avais proposé de nombreuses
choses avec qui ça et je voulais
absolument qu'ils fassent des choses
seul parce que j'ai je croyais en lui à
fond en tant qu'animateur et c'est vrai
que w9 était plus rapide et ils ont eu
le nez creux parce qu'il ça cartonne il
est excellent alors jérôme fouqueray
donc le patron de w9 m'a dit on ne fait
pas cette émission mon cyril voilà il a
été avec moi et m'a dit c'est c'est pas
vrai on est sur une émission et ce n'est
pas une émission de blague
ah voilà donc tout le monde avait la
bonne info je vais vous dire exactement
sur quoi ils sont puisque j'ai l'info et
je sais quel format ils sont en train
sur lequel ils sont en train de
travailler donc merci à jérôme fouqueray
voilà donc les gens
voilà donc on sait pas un concours de
blagues c'est pas un concours de blagues
mais clément garin n'était pas loin
puisque ils sont en train voilà je vous
le dit d'adapter une émission qui
s'appelle les belges contre attaque va
être sur w9 car c'est l'adaptation d'un
concept qui date de 1989 et donc c'est
en fait une équipe belge qui affrontent
une équipe française dans des jeux quizz
et des épreuves fun apparemment ce ne
sont pas ce n'est pas sur des histoires
drôles c'est les belges contre les
français sur des épreuves sur des quiz
il avait des bons éléments il avait les
bons éléments
pardon elle aimait les bons et les
mauvais élèves elle s'est retrouvée avec
des belges effet mansat format qui
existe depuis 30 ans avec des jeux
d'aider des quiz
il avait la bonne affaire 4 et w9 merci
de nous avoir répondu jaune
[Applaudissements]
crp leurs pas et voilà est donc ce sera
des français une équipe belge une équipe
française doivent relever des défis
jouer des sketches qui est qu'ils
s'amuseront des préjugés liés à la
nationalité
voilà le format qu'il prépare et ce sera
peut être pas les blagues et lille
samedi
mais c'est pas avec moi cette émission
ce sera même pas avec qui ça il sera
prêt pas autre chose voilà les chéris